好 明天的話
日央可能也要升息
那美國已經在升息了
台灣央行呢
決定不升息
到底這樣的利率環境
會對資金流向
造成什麼樣的影響呢
谷魚還是很看好
我們的電子股外銷
這邊來請教谷魚了
升息不怕 為什麼不怕呢
因為我們沒有升
對 沒有錯
很多房貸族啊
股票指押族
其實還有點擔心
我們升息這件事
那我們就可以安心的來賺
強勢美元喔
那大家就问了
主动式的基金
好像比主动式的ETF绩效好
那我要怎么选啊
这个背后其实是有一些条件的
那当然我们待会儿呢
花一点时间
来帮各位投资朋友做一个说明
那首先啊
我们的央行啊
在刚刚呢
宣布了他最新的开会结果
那这个开会的结果啊
搭配昨天呢
美国的联总会宣布的结果
两相一对照之下
我馬上對台灣的電子股充滿了信心
那我們先來理解一個問題
那通常來講的話
一旦聯準會他宣布升息
就代表他的貨幣會變得比較強勁一點
那我們的匯率是跟美元做對照的
那一般來講
我們要避免我們的匯率被拉開
最好是要做同步升息的一個動作
所以昨天他宣布升息之後
我們就預期今天有可能會升息個半馬
甚至能達到一碼的一個水準
因為我們已經太久沒有去動這個利率了
對 沒有錯
怎麼會忍得住呢
人家已經升了
日本也要升了
對 沒有錯
但是我們這次開出來的結果的話
大出所有人的意料之外
忍住了
他繼續動漲
對呀
那這樣子一來的話呢
人家在強勢
那我們是動漲
就代表我們的匯率會變弱
你要知道
台灣是一個出口導向的地方
尤其是我們的電子科技相關的產品
你的匯率越弱
就代表我的產品越好賣
所以這樣子一來一往之後的話
我又對我們的電子科技產業的話
充滿了無比的一個信心
賺美元
而且他這一次的宣布來講的話
還有兩個比較特殊的
除了動漲之外
另外一個的話是你的貸款的層數
第二戶從六成的話放寬到七成
而且還有一個是對建商是大利多
什麼東西
就是購地貸款的部分
原本是說呢 你這筆錢借出來之後
在一定的時間內一定要動工
那這條的話呢 也拿掉了
所以你看喔 在這一次
央行的會議來講的話呢
對房地產這一塊
基本上就是一個大利多的表現嘛
那明天會不會也漲營建資產啊
我覺得這個可能性應該是蠻高的啦
就營建跟資產相關的
目前看起來的話呢
對這一塊原本的管制的話
是出現很明確鬆綁的一個現象
那當然對我們來講的話
更重要的是看科技相關的類股
就算台灣升息了
我們一定要切記一件事情
一旦我買的個股
它的成長率比升息的幅度
還要猛烈的時候
那你就不需要太擔心了
確實 因為我們今天在等這個答案
其實就算今天我們申辦碼或一碼好了
對於電子股來說
應該也是小菜一碟
對 沒有錯
我們要會賺錢的龍頭
這才是最重要的啊
所以你看我這邊就幫各位整理啦
2026年的EPS的預估
然後更重要的話呢
是2027年的EPS的預估
剛幸福還特別講到
明年台積電130到150
你直接估一個142.2
這不是我估的喔
這是法人的資料喔
平均資料是不是
對對對
這法人估出來的平均資料喔
而且呢
我們現在已經快要接近到Q4了嘛對啊進到Q4大家都不是看2026 EPS的嗎就开始转看2027的嘛所以呢我就帮你把这份珍贵的资料我们整理下来
然后呢
我们就来看哦
有哪些公司
它在成长性的部分哦
基本上
法人还是一路非常的看好
当然我们在投资啊
事实上
困难度还是蛮高的啦
我真的觉得困难度很高
你看刚刚
我们的报价听王
讲到全新对不对
对
我们的价值股达人
也講全新欸
嚇死我了
8月19號
谷魚獨家來講
零化音是什麼
還把化學元素表放在這邊
對對對
哇 那一天到現在
漲了35%欸
對 沒錯
我真的好失驚
可是我們剛剛在
維泰哥的嘴中的話
也看到了一個
非常驚人的一個消息
就是台光電
事實上在近期的一個表現
突然有墜落的一個現象
可是它的業績很好
對 它業績很好
剛剛也看了
明年我剛剛看了
從EPS要漲到200多塊
對 但是為什麼它會掉下來呢
就是因為有傳出一些謠言
是嗎
我覺得這個還不一定
而且剛剛維泰也說了嘛
那個GPU不一定是兩三年後的事情
你現在就這麼擔心它幹什麼呢
所以你看
當大家很恐慌的時候
結果它的量全部都被人家接走了
所以今天去
把它賣低的這些投資朋友的話
你有可能是錯殺了這一張股票
我們以前常常在講一件事情
你如果自己沒有辦法選股
那你就交給專業的
幫你處理就好了啊
那我們以前都說
專業的要找誰
專業的話當然除了找我之外
更重要的話呢
是你可以考慮
透過主動式的ETF
因為它背後是有專業的經理人
跟專業的選股團隊
他來幫你做操盤的一個動作
我們來看一下
同時間已經發行的這些
主動式的ETF
我也全部都幫你整理在這個地方
01 2 3 4 5
對對對
這樣子一路下來的話
全部的斬別幅都在這裡
哎呀 我跟你說
幾乎每一檔
都把我們的加權指數
按在地上摩擦
除了當然訴求高息
有另外的功能之外
訴求績效的
alpha指的都是贏大盤
全部都是贏過大盤
而且你看
就算是訴求高息的這一檔
它也有將近五成的一個表現
有一個問題來了
奇怪咧
這些經理人當初都有操盤基金
對
那他又有基金又有主動式ETF
現在手心手背怎麼選
我們先來看
這個交出來的成果到底差多少
同一位經理人
譬如說同一位經理人
譬如說呢
我們的這個所謂的那個
那個陳川堯經理人
我們的堯池金母
堯池金母
那他操盤00981A
對啊
然後這個績效非常的漂亮
那可是他同時呢
在共同基金的話呢
它也操盤統一奔騰基金
也是有名的
那我們來看一下
以相同的時間點來看
怎麼樣怎麼樣
那981A
總共交出了
接近205%的一個報酬率
還是很強
非常的強
可是
怎麼樣
它操盤的共同基金的話
是217.4%
可能它有做一些區別吧
區別嗎
對不對
這個區別比你想要中的小很多
我今天幫你
把它
那個持股最大的這個六成
全部都拉出來給你看
這麼殘忍啊
我全部拉出來之後
來 趙華
好的
你幫我注意看
我注意看
有沒有長得不一樣的地方
現在是用那個兩個圖比
對
圈起來哪裡不一樣
我們先不要看比例
我們先看成分股的部分
有沒有哪裡不一樣
我必須說
其實除了排行不一樣
八檔好像一模一樣
對 沒有錯
根本就是一模一樣
同樣的八檔
對
所以你有沒有發現
他去超盤主動式ETF
跟他超販工融基金事實上呢他買的成分股完全一模一樣是但是呢他就交出不一樣的一個績效為什麼待會我再來解密為什麼那還有另外一檔的話呢是00982A這個群毅強榜
陳元毅
陳元毅經理人
他操盤的
他另外呢
還有操盤
那個群毅馬拉松基金
齊健行基金
然後也是一樣喔
相同的時間點
我們來看一下
那個00982A
交出了148%
然後呢
在共同基金的部分的話呢
交出接近155%
然後裡面其中也有超過4成的一個比例
它的個股是漲得完全一模一樣
但是這邊真的有不一樣
我剛才特地提早先看
有的有穿壺他沒有嘛
對不對 有盛輝他沒有 愛撲
但是趙華我還要跟你講一件事情
我如果今天把成分股再拉長一點的話
它重疊的程度就會變大了
對 因為我這邊的話
為了版面的關係
我只拉大概前八檔出來看
所以你才會看到這樣子一個結果
所以你會發現
其實他們在主動式基金跟共融基金的話
他操盤成分股
相似度非常非常的高
但是那為什麼會繳出
完全不一樣的一個績效表現呢
重點就來了
主動式ETF跟共同基金
有一個地方完全不同
就是主動式ETF
他要每天公佈成分股
每天公佈還要接受公平
對 他要接受大家的一個審判
可是共同基金的話不用
他就每個月公佈
一個月公佈
每個月公佈個前十大就好了
一季才需要做完整的揭露
那這兩個差異之下的話呢
其實在主動式的ETF
第一個它很容易出現跟單效應
大家會看到你換股就衝進去嘛
然後另外一個的話呢
有人會想要去狙擊你的成分
狙擊效應
對 那還有另外一個的話呢
是評價效應
特定的個股
譬如說國差嘛 對不對
可能經理人很想要做一些動作
可是大家都盯著看啊
那怎麼辦呢 你有沒有賣 你有沒有賣
大家都盯著看的時候
那我就乾脆就不動了嘛 對不對
所以導致它在操作的彈性會變差
也就是因為有這些因素的話
反倒是造成
共同基金不用揭露
所以它有比較多的一個空間
可以來做操盤的一個動作
就會教出比較好的一個績效
而且我們必須坦白說一件事情
台灣的這些共同基金
真的非常的強
我們來幫各位統計一下
你如果做單筆投資跟做定期定額
藍色的這一條是我們的加選指數
紅色的這一條的話呢
是我們台股平均的
績效表現
是
遙遙領先
這是台股基金平均喔
不是拿什麼很厲害的
這是平均而已
而且呢我們今天幫上面列的
它都不是小規模的喔
然後呢它也不是說呢
昨天剛冒出來的共同基金喔
它在市場上都有成立超過30年以上
規模百億對不對
成立30年其實很猛喔
因為現在的ETF都千億
其實基金百億就是大規模
是大规模
对 它是大规模
而且呢
它已经经历过
非常完整
拨空的一个循环了
30年
30年啊 你看
30年耶
能够屹立30年
它的操作的一个方式
逻辑跟绩效
肯定可以受到
投资朋友的一个信赖
是
所以你看我今天就把这些
所有的绩效表的话
全部都整理在这边
对
那我们的投资朋友的话呢
来做一个参考
那我这边如果有打一个新号
新星的
代表呢
它在TESA级别的话呢
是可以买得到的哦
好 等一下会来介绍
有所謂的TESA級別是什麼意思
就是省錢的意思
對 就是超省錢的意思
超省錢
超省錢的意思
其實不難選啦
剛剛我們第一張列那個表裡面
就非常多這樣的基金了
可是你在買基金的時候
有一件事情一定要幫我注意
因為基金跟買股票買ETF
有個地方不太一樣
它有很多的平台
那比如說你可以在投信公司買基金
你也可以在銀行買基金
那或者是說你可以在基金平台或是像我們之前常常介紹這個基附通基通 我想只要長期看理財達人秀的人都不陌生了就是基金的購買平台
那為什麼我們過去呢
直接跟投資朋友介紹基附通
因為很簡單嘛
第一個 申購手續費
零
然後第二個 信託管理費
好了 贏了贏了
而且你看喔
它還有APP可以用喔
然後他還有理財輔助的功能
也可以用基金借貸 基金減減
甚至低檔自動加碼
然後另外一個的話
基督中本身
他也是一個中立性的平台
所以你今天如果在投資的過程當中
買基金一定要幫我注意一件事情
挑對平台
真的對你的整體的擁有成本
能夠有大幅度下降的一個效果
你省下的每一分錢
就是你未來成長的一個動力
好 中立性很重要
你去某投信
當然就是買某投信的基金
去銀行 銀行可能也會有
他退佣什麼的想法
你在這上面
你就愛選什麼就選什麼
對 而且他上面的資料
非常的完整
可以隨便的你來做
那個觀看的一個動作
那當然這個
基附東這個平台
我們會跟投資朋友
做一個介紹一個原因的話
是說我在投資的過程中
有一些策略跟想法
他全部都幫你
都包好了
都包在平台內了
比如說像標的物的部分的話
我們剛剛有看到
它整體提供標的物的選擇
有高達3000檔以上
絕對夠讓你慢慢選
而且更重要的話呢
上面也有TISA級別的一個機品
它有好的工具
而且它可以幫你自動紀律執行的話呢
你就好好的做下去就對了
但是呢 除此之外
基附通還有一個非常特殊的功能
我們過去講了很多次的
就是低檔的自動扣這樣子的一個功能
那這個功能的好處是什麼
之前7月的時候回檔比較深
確實就扣很多次
而且他非常感謝自己就是說
他是設定自動化的一個機制
你如果讓他自己去投他會怕
會猶豫
可是自動化的機制他一覺醒來的話
工作一忙不小心就全部都扣完了
結果在回溫的過程中
開心啊對不對
沒想到績效這樣子就自動往上走了
可以優先考慮
基督通這樣子的一個平台
他隨著時間過去
他整體的一些配套跟產品
都越來越豐富了
非常值得我們投資朋友
來做一個考慮
好 剛剛講的當然是以台股基金為主
對不對
那台股基金因為波動性相對
也比較高一點
很適合低檔自動投
因為它下去的時候
你會怕就讓我們的AI智慧
當你做決定
沒有錯
今天非常謝謝谷瑜
好 谷瑜有看到
現在美國在升息
那我們的央行動漲的話
美元有可能走強
對於我們電子股的外銷
其實是一個強心針
對於明年我們的發展
還是十分的看好
那当然刚刚也独家比较了
到底主动式的ETF跟主动式的基金
各自有优缺点啦
但是现在基金如果搭配着像基附通这样的平台
里面有帮你在下跌的时候低档自动投
也可以有所谓的TESA级别让您了解一下
省了手续费管理费等等的
这个基金的成本一旦降低竞争力也随之拉上来
很值得您做参考留意
尤其是小资组几千块就可以开始了
当然赵槐是要提醒
不管投资ETF投资基金都是有赚
有賠有風險的
賺購錢一定要享樂公開說明書喔
好 今天非常謝謝三位來賓來到現場
好 美國升息我們動漲
這樣的情況下
到底會對台股市場造成什麼樣的影響
我們回歸產業裡面
今天有跟大家聊了
如果是明年成長性更高的
我想第四季大家放心
因為過去的勝率真的是相當的高
那也希望今天的理財答案秀
對你投資有幫助喔
明天再會了 掰掰
by bwd6